a Wild West party has made more than a
few people livid after American actor
and comedian Kevin Hart held a themed
event for his one-year-old son's
birthday
his wife posted several images of the
party on Instagram showing their friends
and family clad in native
american-inspired tribal print blankets
not made many angry online saying that
playing cowboys and Indians is well not
acceptable anymore
cowboys and Indians can you not afford a
publicist who would explain the reality
if such a terrible idea
throwing a cowboys and Indians birthday
party on Thanksgiving celebrates
genocide white supremacy and slavery
maybe next year he could have a master
slave owners and slaves party people
need to understand the genocide of
indigenous people in this country it was
horrific and nothing cute about it stop
perpetuating this as cute it's not well
Kevin Hart himself wall no of America's
biggest entertainment stars hit back he
says the criticism he's been getting
points to some deep problems in modern
culture the shows just how stupid our
world is becoming with opinion people
are at a point of an all-time high to
throw racial judgment into the
development of a one-year-olds birthday
party with the theme is cowboys and
Indians and it's in its it's based
around the outfits that are given to
these young kids yeah a lot of people
supporting all people not supporting
that those words because the reaction we
heard really ranged from whether the
party sends the wrong message to
children or is it just innocent toddlers
thing fun and games
conversation worth having here's why the
implications are much broader at first
glance oh it's just a one year olds
birthday party but here's the thing
about it a lot of the decisions we make
as adults are based on information that
we received as children the truth of the
matter is is that some of that
information
with incorrect when you're a child and
you say I want to dress up like an
Indian we could argue whether it's
Indian with their Native American the
child does not say now I get to realize
the fact that these people are racially
inferior to me and they can celebrate
the subjugation of these people by
virtue of white forebears
that's not what happens is so it's a
child who says I like to dress like that
because we've whitewashed history so
much few people are even willing to deal
with it because they're so blind to
what's been really going on around them
as we began to battle back what was
behind this statue or appeal back with
behind this giving celebration we began
slowly go for the real issue when we
played cowboys and Indians we never said
can I play the Cowboys so I can
slaughter the Plains Indian no it was
I'll be the Indian you be the cowboy
we're kids we're pretending but what do
you pretend to do with them you pretend
to shoot them you pretend to tie the
moment you're presiding to shoot them
arrow what we're talking about is little
kids who were innocent at each juncture
of these moments in history where we
unveil the truth we get closer to
addressing the real underlying issue of
racism in America this is going to right
now show the rest of the world with all
due respect than I and I mean this how
absolutely pathetic this is that
seemingly grown adults are talking about
the racial implications and the
appropriation of culture from little
kids who want to dress up like Indians
you